regardez ce que j'ai trouvé au fond du
jardin bien à l'abri sous le feuillage
comme tous les escargots ils attendent
la pluie pour mettre le nez dehors en
fin d'année le pied plus tôt
et oui cette masse charnue sous la
coquille c'est son pied les escargots
appartiennent à la classe des
gastéropodes littéralement viscères osé
sur le pied en facile de se déplacer
dans ces conditions pour limiter les
efforts les escargots produisent un
liquide visqueux un mucus qui a pour but
de réduire les frottements mais ce qu'il
préfère c'est la pluie pas besoin de se
fatiguer à produire du lubrifiant le sol
glisse naturellement et dans ces
conditions ils peuvent parcourir 600 qui
mettra la minute le temps d'une capsule
de des conflits nés quand on est là une
douzaine
qu'est ce que je veux en faire deux
équipes de volley
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents en cliquant
sur le côté gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle par jour et
pour ne louper aucune et bien abonnez
vous et activer la petite cloche aller à
demain n'oubliez pas nous sommes
toujours confiné mais on reste en lien